a high profile couple implicated in the
college admissions scandal is
cooperating with prosecutors that could
mean trouble for parents who have not
yet been charged Davina and Bruce
Isaacson pleaded guilty in court
yesterday they admitted to paying a six
hundred thousand dollar bribe Jamie
yuccas is at UCLA where one of their
daughters gained admission Jamie good
morning good morning one of the
Isaacson's two daughters was admitted
here to UCLA after her parents took part
in the scheme now by cooperating
experts say the couple could tell
investigators about other school
officials coaches or even friends who
might also be involved Bruce and Davina
Isaacson left a Boston federal
courthouse Wednesday after pleading
guilty to paying six hundred thousand
dollars in bribes to guarantee that
their two daughters would be admitted
into USC and UCLA of the 14 parents
who've agreed to plead guilty they're
the only two who've entered into
cooperation agreement so far Justin
Paperny serve time for fraud and is now
a prison consultant working with clients
involved in the scheme including a
parent who will plead guilty
well the defendants that get these deals
are usually the ones who accept
responsibility first and who have the
most to offer and that could include
rolling over on friends family
colleagues according to the Los Angeles
Times a couple from China who has not
been charged paid the schemes mastermind
Rick singer the most of any parent six
point five million dollars to get their
daughter into Stanford
in a statement to CBS News Stanford says
it did not receive six and a half
million dollars from singer or from a
student's family working with singer it
says it was not aware of the reported
payment before yesterday the couple was
reportedly connected to singer through a
Morgan Stanley financial advisor Morgan
Stanley tells CBS News the advisor was
terminated for not cooperating with an
internal investigation into the college
admissions matter it added we are
cooperating with the authorities while
33 parents have been charged including
actresses Lori Lachlan and Felicity
Huffman
prosecutors say they've sent target
letters to three students and there
might be more indictments to come and
according to experts the guapa
operation agreements are making
potential new defendants even more
concerned about what's to come those who
have yet to be charged and more are
coming are living in the land of the the
unknown they are scared 24 hours a day
many are struggling to function and even
work and they're begging for some
clarity at least three other parents
here in California have been contacted
for their dealings with Ric singer
according to a source close to those
involved they have hired attorneys but
have not been charged one parent tells
our source they haven't slept they're
terrified they've ruined their child's
future Gail no it's a very good question
thank you very much Jamie I wonder how
many people are quaking in their boots
wondering is it ham we're gonna come
down next but there's something I think
really crappy that if you get caught now
I'm going to flip on other people no you
can't hang at night in town yeah
something nuts all right about that I
think